how you doing yeah I'm good I'm good
I've seen you more than I see some of my
friends that's great
it's been a busy uh busy month or two so
I like putting on Twitter that then I'm
gonna talk to people sometimes I get fun
questions and I got one for you okay so
here we go
for Jamie this is from Once Upon a
Dornan the person that's there that's
their handler who they're fun of for
Jamie he said in an interview that he
loves the animated version of Robin Hood
and had a crush on meet Marian the Fox
was this the real motivation as to why
you took the movie the only motivation
yet no but it is cool because I do love
that and I definitely did slash do have
a crush on Maid Marian the Fox in the
Disney animation version but you know
it's it very cool and it's obviously so
many other reasons I want to do but it
is cool too not just that unprincipled
Scott's version and even the Errol Flynn
ones I have always loved this story and
I remember how excited I was to go and
see Prince of Thieves when I was 11
years old and I remember that like it
was yesterday that trip to the cinema
I remember the car journey there I just
remember everything about it and to be
involved in something and hopefully some
some kids somewhere or you know have a
similar kind of excitement to see it and
be involved in that that's a very cool
thing one of the things about this
version is that almost everything's
flipped on its head yes and the thing I
think my favorite part is that the
sheriff is not interested romantically
in Marion mm-hmm like it's just sure
absolutely different sure can you talk
about that aspect of the film yeah I
mean I think we wanted to feel like
nothing you've seen before depicted with
a Robin Hood story and would mess a
little bit with our idea of what what we
think it's gonna be you know and I guess
that the love triangle then is different
to what we know with past Robin Hood's
and it becomes about my character will
Tillman and Robin and Marian which just
adds a whole different dynamic to and
obviously that what happens within that
love triangle has a big effect on the
journey that my character goes through
um a sort of unrecognizable at the end
of the film from when we see him at the
start and that was without giving too
much away that was the thing that
excited me most of
about this journey yeah there's a lot of
things I'd like to talk about that would
get a beep with a spoiler warning yes um
and so I'll just say that another point
we will follow up on what I would like
to talk about I hope so yeah you know
what I mean yeah I would imagine that
making this one of the things I also
took away was I couldn't believe how
many extras were in the mines yes like I
couldn't believe the scale of what you
guys were doing cuz you know it's hard
to get that many extras in the movie
though sure so what was it like filming
when you have like hundreds of people
there well I've never experienced never
like that I've never been on a set so
sort of grandiose in its scale and and
they mind the people involved and they
might have effects happening on fire and
the horses galloping fear is like lunacy
at times and but it's very it's very
exciting you know adds a real sort of
palpable sense of excitement to what
we're doing you know when we shot it in
Budapest in Hungary where they have a
huge industry that is they I mean
they're shooting massive movies I've
read spyro was being shot while we were
there so I think that's a great
infrastructure for all that and they
have so many extras and great crews and
you have a super cool experience
I'm playing something with a lot of a
lot of people and today you're gonna
play called get to know your Robin Hood
cast member that's where the harmless
question okay what TV show would you
love to guest spot on it doesn't exist
anymore but I would have said the Golden
Girls I love the girl who goes I wasn't
the answer I was expecting but it's um
no I probably should say something
better wait how did you look we have a
line bloodline sure but let's let's go
backwards where did you first discover
your love of the Golden Girls
oh listen Otis is a staple and TV
growing up where I came from I'm such a
member of the Estelle Getty fan club
legit no lies right for real yeah for
real okay again there's so many
follow-ups to that but let's move on
what's your favorite sci-fi or fantasy
film Oh
a Space Odyssey probably yeah is there
anything that you collect no I did again
when I was a kid I got a stamp
collection passed on to me from my
father and I think
he was disappointed at how little I
added to it so no I I know I don't
collect anything no uh I used to collect
a hotel keys okay I would never give my
hotel key back and in my rucksack when I
travelled a lot like like 20s I just had
like a load of like hotel keys did you
label like where the keys were fit was
ago I wasn't as organized as that
they're all just like loose hanging
around I just threw them away one day I
recycled them sorry I don't I don't
think he recycled uh do you own any
movie or TV show props oh I don't know
no I don't I've got a couple of you know
like the back of my my chair with my
name on them in a cupboard somewhere I
think but nothing you haven't thought
about like like cuz there's some cool
costumes in this movie no I really
wanted to take one jacket in particular
one coat that will where's but then I
bottled it and just didn't they good I
didn't ask
Oh background photo on your phone well
it's my family my kids I was going to
show you but that would be weird yeah
it's also a holiday in France and I have
my youngest on my shoulders and my
wife's carrying the other what films
scared you as a kid oh I saw The
Exorcist way younger than I was meant to
you could get it at the the petrol
station at gas station whatever at the
top of our road they had like a bargain
bucket and this was years after came out
and I was with an older friend and they
bought it and we watched and I shouldn't
watch it
is there a TV show that you've watched
all all the way through more than once
besides the Golden Girls all the way
through more than once
yeah Band of Brothers I thought I did
that twice I am in the process of
debating whether this start Sopranos
again just because it was not good and
I haven't been as affected by television
as I have by this problem so I might
just give that another um but this Prime
my last question I'm always curious how
people got involved in the entertainment
industry and by the young age was there
something that you saw a performance or
movie that said oh my god I want to do
this know I wanted to be involved in
sports that's right up intelligibly 20
probably so no I you know I'd always
don't drama and stuff at school and
outside of it but never it's one thing
to love the idea of doing it and it's
another thing to be mad enough to think
you get paid it you know I did still
think it's a bit math but obviously it's
you know I'm doing it but it's um no I
mean my dad was a massive Steve Martin
fan so I mean I remember I remember the
first time I saw the jerk probably going
like that would you know that would be
cool but and then not thinking I could
actually I'm not saying I'm Steve Martin
in the dark but like those interviews
gone off the rails in six different ways
so if people are gonna take the headline
you know he thinks he's the Steve as
good as Steve Martin yeah please don't
make that up
I'm joking huh Congrats on the movie
thank you so much for giving me your
time thanks
you